Hey Thoughty2 here.
Have you ever had a burning question which
you've always wanted answered, but you've
never known where to turn, or who to ask?
Well now's your chance to get it answered,
once and for all.
I'm so excited to finally be able to announce
my shiny, new website, Thoughty2.com.
It's a fantastic way to keep up with my latest
uploads and read the full transcripts of all
my videos.
It's also the first place on the internet,
along with YouTube, that you will find my
new videos as soon as they are released.
But, most importantly, you can go to Thoughty2.com
and ask me any question.
For example "Why is the sky blue?" or "What
are black holes?".
It can be about science, maths, history, entertainment,
lifestyle, or simply general knowledge.
Pretty much no topic is off limits!
Once you've posted your question anyone can
vote it up.
You can also vote up other people's questions
if you think they should be answered.
Every week the questions that have the most
up-votes, I will answer with a video, right
here on YouTube, for everyone to see.
My goal with these video's is to answer your
questions in the simplest way possible so
everyone can understand it, but at the same
time, keeping it concise and entertaining.
So be sure to visit Thoughty2.com and check
it out.
The website will be constantly evolving with
more features being added so you guys can
get more and more out of it as time goes on.
I hope it can be a place for the Thoughty2
community to come together and help make Thoughty2
better and more enjoyable for everyone.